tell us how much pat did was he full was
he limited how much pat did and uh um
how he looked when he was out there as
well
yeah um so he looked good he's just uh
he's in the protocol so there's only
certain things he can do and
it's a limited basis but
today is a little bit limited practice
so he this fit right into what he could
do and
and um but he took all the snaps and
you know he feels
he feels good so i mean we just we're
just going to follow this protocol
as close as we possibly can does
anything really change offensively in
terms of the game planning with patrick
in the protocol and obviously chad going
through most of the reps or does it
mostly stay the same
yeah you know when chad was in the game
we didn't have to really change much so
um that was a plus and
and um
so we've kind of we're just leaving it
the way we we do chad's comfortable with
it
and
you know he he feels that he can handle
that if needed so i think
that's
all well there
according to the injury report posted at
the chief's website patrick mahomes was
limited in practice with a concussion
slash toe injury and we we knew there
was a toe problem we saw that he was
favoring the foot before he exited the
game with the concussion he's in the
protocol and i'm always confused by this
you can be in the protocol without
actually having a concussion you still
have to pass the protocol even if you
didn't have a full-blown concussion and
it's all very amorphous and vague and
there isn't a whole lot of transparency
the bottom line is he needs to be
cleared whether he had an actual
concussion i've seen all sorts of
speculation it was some sort of a neck
thing and it it created a nerve issue
and that's why he was he's in the
concussion protocol it doesn't matter he
doesn't play he doesn't qualify for
contact practice until he can clear that
protocol shireen and look i i think that
that the toe is something i'd be more
concerned about at this point i have no
doubt he's going to play on sunday i
have no doubt that all appropriate boxes
will be checked and he will be cleared
to play i would be stunned if he beyond
stunned if he's not cleared because of
the concussion i want to see how he
moves with that toe and i want to see if
that
restricts his game in any way because it
sure looked like it was affecting him
between plays and it felt like it was
just a matter of time before it looked
like it was going to affect him during
plays yeah i'm with you mike i initially
i was worried about the concussion it's
a five-step process and andy reid didn't
address where exactly patrick mahomes
was in that process and initially they
did list him as a full participant and
now apparently have changed that to
limited and i think they realized you
can't be a full participant unless
you've been cleared from concussion
protocol so obviously that hasn't
happened but we do expect him to play he
has not had symptoms of a concussion
andy reid said that so that's not gonna
be the problem i'm with you i think the
toe injury could be the bigger problem
how well is he gonna move we know that's
a big part of his game and last time
they played uh the bills he rushed for
over 30 yards
in that game and was very effective
moving around in the pocket as he always
is but how much is that going to limit
him we saw him limping a lot and i know
andy reid blew off that injury on monday
but i still think it could be a factor
mike and it could be a factor from the
fact that he's not going to get a ton
probably of practice time this week
because of that toe i would expect him
to be limited all week whether it is the
concussion of the toe or both
the official injury report distributed
by the nfl also has mahomes listed as
limited in practice but just by way of
an example as to how what ends up on the
website can be different from the
official report i'll give you an example
that that it just jumped right out to me
on the chief's website they've got the
chiefs injuries and the bills injuries
and it shows stefan diggs did not
practice with an oblique injury the
email from the league
shows that stefan diggs was limited in
practice with an oblique injury so may i
just make
a friendly suggestion get your act
together nfl and teams this is fairly
important information on which people
rely how hard is it it's either did not
practice limited or full it ain't that
difficult and i see these mistakes all
the time there was a weird injury report
last week on the saints website on
friday that had michael thomas's out and
it's like he's not even on the injury
report this week so i don't get it i
don't understand it and i'm surprised
there isn't more of an outcry because
people are relying on this information
especially when it comes to deciding who
they're going to bet on or not bet on in
a given game so
to to borrow a phrase from uh a guy that
i really don't think much of personally
mike gundy get your facts straight nfl
all right um you know the other thing
that i wonder about the chiefs in this
patrick mahomes situation shireen is
that
will they
let him run will they design runs will
he
choose not to run if no one's open
because of the tow and because of the
hey i just had a concussion last week so
i i don't think mahomes is going to
restrict himself in any way i don't know
if andy reid will restrict patrick
mahomes as a runner but i think that's
something that if i'm the bills leslie
frazier the defensive coordinator of
sean mcdermott the head coach i'm
wondering as i budget my resources my 11
guys
how
how
in tune are they going to be to the
possibility of my homes running or are
we going to assume he's not going to run
because of those injuries
i'm going after him mike i'm going after
him early if he hits a big one to tr
tyree kill so be it i mean you know the
chiefs are going to score points this is
going to be a high scoring game we all
expect so if they hit the big one
earlier early and he gets out of there
if he runs early or whatever the case
may be and you figure out that toe's
okay and the concussion is fine and he's
going to do what he needs to do then
okay then maybe i change my game plan a
little bit but initially mike i'm going
after him i'm blitzing him i'm trying to
get to him early and and see what i can
do
with him under duress
yeah look i agree with you completely
and i know that there'll be chiefs fans
that
don't want to hear that but that's
football
and i know that i created a little bit
of a mess last year when i suggested
after seeing him weave through all those
titans players who didn't know what they
could and couldn't do and were fearful
of doing something that would get them
flagged for 15 yards and we see
quarterbacks flop now and admit that
they flopped like lamar jackson during
the season and how about how about josh
allen josh allen can play himself in the
josh allen story the acting quality that
we saw when he flopped and drew a
15-yard foul so
it's hey once you become a runner all
bets are off you're no different than
marshawn lynch or
or any other nfl running back that's
ever played and and that's that's where
these guys need to be coached um not
with an intent to injure
but if you you can't take advantage
of the rules that way and you can't kind
of pretend that the bubble that exists
around a quarterback in the pocket
exists when he decides to become a
runner and it'll be interesting to see
whether to what extent the chiefs take
advantage or not of the rules that
protect a quarterback because i don't
think the bill's defense is going to be
looking to go easy on patrick mahomes
under the circumstances
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports